[Applause] I'm sorry, you're a
bad guy, trained in Unite Rounds, but it's
too early to give up on the remaining two minutes. Show your strength. There
are too many people who go berserk just by losing their canes.  If you
seal it and it suddenly becomes active, then you can
go, you bastard, you only have one minute left, dodge, dodge, pull, and run away.  The
chain is so
strong that it exceeds Lycaon's markings, so I can't take any evasive action
as it is.I want it back so bad, why
don't you go get it?  But then you just
punched him and you won, but you're the only one who seems stubborn.
[Music] It's not the
end. It's just a
condition decided by Kamaora on his own, but it's okay.
Well,
[Music] I'm
sure you showed me your
soul.